not long ago these warships were
stationed in Crimea now the pitiful
remnants of Ukraine's Navy sit in
odessa's harbor but the Russians are
here too
up in the city a hundred pro-russian
militia men calling themselves Odessa
Liberation are camped behind a wall of
sandbags the past few days we have no
longer been able to control the more
radically minded people deed these
activists are openly calling for Odessa
to follow Crimea script first hold a
referendum then join the Russian
Federation Russia is a strong presence
in Transnistria 70 kilometers northwest
of Odessa the region along the east bank
of the kneestr River broke away from
Moldova in 1992 and is closely linked to
Moscow Transnistria openly supports
odessa's pro-russian separatists the
Ukrainian government is trying to stop
pro-russian forces from entering Ukraine
from Transnistria Europe is helping
German policeman andreas nasha is at the
border as part of the EU border
assistance mission to Moldova I joined
the German border police force in 1988
back then Germany was separated into
East and West I'm reminded of that
whenever I'm on a mission like this this
border separates Ukraine and it's
pro-west government from Transnistria an
authoritarian state propped up by Moscow
we drive to the capital tiraspol 30
minutes away we pass Russian army bases
Russian troops have been stationed in
Transnistria since 1992 many people here
urine for what they see as the past
glory of the Soviet Union we visit a
village near the Moldovan border and
chat with Svetlana Simone Nova who runs
a small grocery store food gas and
electricity are very cheap thanks to
subsidies from Moscow
like most people here see manova has a
low opinion of the EU and she wants
Transnistria to join the Russian
Federation nobody here wants here if all
of us want Russia young people to
Transnistria has officially applied for
accession to the Russian Federation a
stone's throw away from Simone OVAs
village across the border is the village
of Donetsk Oh yo in Moldova
Valentina Nicole Eva's husband fought
for Moldova against Moscow back to
Transnistrian separatist soldiers in
1992 but today she wants her country to
join the Russian Federation - personally
I'm for joining Russia why because I
want to live like we did back then
Moldova is the poorest country in Europe
the people who live in Transnistria
enjoy extra retirement pay and other
benefits for Moscow but Valentina lives
outside the breakaway republic so she
got a trends in history and Passport so
she too could get the benefits
Transnistrian citizenship I worked over
there back in the 80s and paid my taxes
there a growing number of young
Moldovans are applying for Transnistria
and passports they allow Moldovans to
work legally in Russia though not in
Western Europe no one here has said
anything critical about Russia to us but
we wonder whether the Kremlin may be
using liberal distribution of its
passports to build support among the
population of Moldova a former Soviet
republic to join the Russian Federation